Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt, ich würde Ihnen gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen, die ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Anna Müller, eine 39-jährige Patientin, geboren am 9.07.1986.
Sie ist 1,69 Meter groß und 68 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund seit gestern bestehender, zunehmender, drückender linkseitiger Epigastric Schmelzen mit Ausstrahlung in der rechten Schulter.
Die Schmelzintensität wurde mit 8 von 10 bewertet.
Sie hat deswegen gegen diese Schmelzen 400 Milligramm über Waffen genommen.
Es hat ihr kaum geholfen.
Sie gab es vor einem Monat an, ähnliche Beschwerden zu haben.
Sie beschreibt diese Schmelzen als kolikartig und plötzlich auftretender Schmelzen.
Sie hat auch eine Schleifschmerz- und Begleitsymptome.
Die Frage nach Brustschmelzen, Dispnoe, Husten, Oedema wurde verneint.
Sie klagte seit gestern über das Rasen oder Tachikardi.
Wahrscheinlich wegen des Fiebers.
Wie hoch ist das Fieber?
Sie haben es nicht gemessen, Herr Oberas.
Ich habe es gefragt, aber sie haben es nicht gemessen.
Darüber hinaus klagte sie über Emesis, das war Essensreste.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inappetenz wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Und heller Schutul sowie dunkler Ruin.
Was können wir benutzen für diese Wörter?
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran, Herr Oberas. Entschuldigung.
Kein Problem. Also Hyperbirubinämie können wir sagen.
Und Stereotode, ich denke so.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Machen Sie weiter.
Insomniä wegen dieser Schmerzen.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet sie seit 10 Jahren an Migräne.
Dagegen nimmt sie 10 mg T-Liptan und 400 mg Ibuprofen bei Bedarf ein.
Zudem leidet sie seit 5 Jahren an Hypo-Lipidämie.
Dagegen nimmt sie 20 mg Atovastatin ein.
An arterielle Hypertonie seit 5 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt sie 1. April 10 mg ein.
Sie klagte über Diskushenny seit 2 Jahren.
Die wurde mit kranken Gymnastik und Gewichtsreduktion behandelt.
Dagegen hat sie vor 3 Jahren Gürtel-Göse, die mit Medikamenten behandelt.
Varicella-Soster.
Varicella. Entschuldigung. Varicella-Soster.
Sie wurde noch nie operiert.
Bei ihr sind keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Sie ist nicht Trauerin.
Sie trinkt 2-3 Gläser Wein pro Monat.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie hat 2 gesunden Kinder.
Sie lebt mit seinem Ehemann zusammen.
In der Familienanamnese fand sie arterielle Hypertonie Diabetes mellitus osteoporos bei der Mutter.
Der Vater ist mit 68 Jahren an hochwahrscheinlichem Lebeserose verstorben.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Frauenanamnese ist unauffällig.
Sie treibt regelmäßig Sport.
Meine Verdachtstheatose lautet auf Cholestitis.
Dafür schiebt sich die Lokalisation des Schmelzen.
Die Schmelzen sind nahrungsabhängig.
Die Schmelzen sind nach dem fertigen Abendessen aufgetreten.
Die Lokalisation des Schmelzen ist auch schiebt sich auf Cholestitis.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik ist akute Pancreatitis, Ulcus ventriculi, Cholelytiasis.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach werde ich die Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und oskiltieren.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich auf den Allgemeinen Zustand der Patienten und die Hautverfärbung.
Bei der Cholestitis können wir Ikterus sehen.
Leidet der Patient unter Ikterus?
Ich habe es gefragt. Es ist ihm nicht aufgefallen.
Hat er Pulitis?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung kann ich es fragen.
Bei Verdacht auf Cholestitis ist eine Palpation nötig.
Bei der Palpation beurteile ich die Schmelzen und Abwehrspannung.
Ich erwarte bei der Cholestitis Abwehrspannung im rechten Oberbau.
Ich überprüfe in diesem Fall Murphy-Zeichen.
Können Sie bitte das Zeichen erklären?
Beim rechten Oberbau tasten wir die Patienten einatmen.
Beim Einatmen gibt es das Zeichen für Murphy-Zeichen.
Ich werde dann die Blutuntersuchung durchführen.
Ich werde die Blutbild- und Leberwerte überprüfen.
Ich werde die Pancreatitis ausdrücken.
Um die Pancreatitis auszuschließen, werde ich die Amylase, die Lipase und die alkaliere Phosphatase überprüfen.
Ich werde die Blutwerte überprüfen.
Ich habe es vergessen.
Die Blutwerte sind nötig.
Im nächsten Schritt werde ich die Diagnostik durchführen.
Um eine mögliche Herzkrankheit auszuschließen, werde ich zunächst ein EKG schreiben.
In diesem Fall ist Sonographie nötig.
Bei der Sonographie können wir Gallenblase darstellen.
Und die andere mögliche Pathologie können wir auch auszuschließen.
Denken Sie an einen Gallenstein bei diesen Patienten?
Ich denke an diesen Patienten.
Gallenstein und Polycystitis.
Warum?
Es ist auch klassisch.
Vor einem Monat hatte sie ähnliche Beschwerden.
Nach dem Fertiges Essen ist sie aufgetreten.
Und Polylytiasis ist ein Risikofaktor für Polycystitis.
Deswegen vermute ich Polylytiasis.
Okay, machen Sie weiter.
Wenn die Befunde unklar sind, würde ich CT des Abdomens veranlassen.
CT des Abdomens ist Goldstandard, um eine Polylytiasis darzustellen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstheatose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Zunächst würde ich einen Venözugang legen, um eine intravenöse Therapie zu ermöglichen.
Danach würde ich ausreichende Flüssigkeit verabreichen und Schmessmittel und Antibiotikum verabreichen.
Das ist auch nötig in diesem Fall.
Ich werde eine chirurgische Konzilveranlassung machen, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Würden Sie bei diesen Patienten eine EACP durchführen?
Mit Ergebnissen können wir entscheiden.
Wenn die Steine am Puller weiter sind, können wir eine EACP durchführen.
Und gibt es einen Risikofaktor bei diesen Patienten?
Gibt es ein Cholestas bei diesen Patienten?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich habe gefragt, ob Sie irgendwelche Hautverfarbungen bemerkt haben.
Die Fragen wurden verneint. Bei Cholestas erwarten wir Ikterus.
Das heißt, die jährliche Hautverfarbung ist nicht aufgefallen.
Was ist das denn? Ein heller Stuhl und dunkler Urin?
Was bedeutet das?
Das ist ein Cholestas. Sie haben recht.
Können Sie bitte eine EACP erklären?
EACP ist eine diagnostische Bildgebende-Methode.
Das ist eine komplexe Methode.
Wir können mit Hilfe von Röntgenschall und einem Schlag diese Methode durchführen.
Und einen Schlag können wir durch den Mund einführen.
Und gleichzeitig unter Röntgenschall darstellen.
Das ist nicht nur eine diagnostische Methode, sondern auch eine therapeutische Methode.
Es ist eine schmerzhafte Methode. Wir verbreiten Narkose.
Deswegen müssen die Patienten vor der Untersuchung acht Stunden nüchtern sein.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht man eine Begleitperson. Sie kann nicht Auto fahren.
Okay, gut. Es gibt viele verschiedene Fragen. Aber die Zeit ist abgelaufen.
Ich würde die Patienten vorstellen.
Frau Anna Müller ist 39 Jahre alt und 1,69 Meter groß und 68 Kilogramm schwer.
Die Patienten stellen sich heute bei uns wegen gestern Abend bestehender mittler-rechtsaatlicher-effizienziger Schmerzen vor.
Der Patient ist zufolge die Schmerzen drückender, kolikartiger und dünner.
Sie erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden sind.
Außerdem berichtet sie, dass die Schmerzen in der rechten Schulter ausstrahlen.
Die Beschwerden gehen mit Neusea, Amalige, Emesis, Akulische Stuhl, Vigette und Bilirubin-Uri einher.
Die Einnahme von Ibuprofen 400 mg hat wenige Verbesserungen gebracht.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 7 bis 8 Fondsen auf eine Schmerzkala bewertet.
Die Frage nach Hautfarbeveränderungen wurde verneint.
Die Patienten berichten, dass die Beschwerden nach dem Fettigen Essen aufgetreten sind.
Die vegetative Anamnese sind folgende Ergebung.
Die Schmerzen werden mit der Anamnese entgegengebracht und mit der Schmerzen entgegengebracht.
Die Anforderungen sind die Nanteze.
Seit 10 Jahren ist es eine Migrantenkrise.
Seit 5 Jahren ist es eine Hyperlipidemie.
Seit 5 Jahren ist es eine arterielle Hypertonik.
Seit 3 Jahren ist es eine Hypertest.
Die Operation ist unaufällig.
In der Medikation nimmt sie 10 mg Triptan und 500 mg Ibuprofen.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Sie trinkt 1 bis 3 Flaschen Wein.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig. Sie trinkt 1 bis 3 Flaschen Wein.
Die Anamnese trinkt 1 bis 3 Flaschen Wein.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei Kinder. Die Kinder sind gesund.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Cholelytiasis aus.
Die Patienten haben typische Symptome.
Die Patienten leiden über rechte abdominalen Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind in der rechten Schulter aus.
Außerdem hat die Patienten eine akkulische Stuhl- und Bilirubin-Urine.
Das spricht für Cholelytiasis.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Urkusventruchili, Akut Pancreatitis und Nefrolithiasis in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten die vitalen Parameter überwachen.
Dann werde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich die Schmerzen abweichen und die Druckschmerzen vorlegen.
Dann werde ich die Schmerzen abweichen.
Herr Kollegen, kennen Sie Mörfezeichen?
Ich kenne die Mörfezeichen.
Wir palpieren die Patienten in der rechten Oberbauchung oder Unterrippen.
Wir wollen die Patienten einatmen.
Wenn die Patienten einatmen, wird ein Schmerz aus der Oberbauchung.
Was bedeutet Mörfezeichen positiv?
Mörfezeichen positiv bedeutet eine Kolesistitis.
Machen Sie weiter.
Außerdem werden wir die Hautfarbe verändern.
Dann werde ich die Patienten auskühlen.
Dann werde ich die Haut verändern.
Wenn die Patienten körperlich untersuchen, werden sie die Schmerzen abweichen.
Dann werde ich die Schmerzen abweichen.
Dann werden wir die Schmerzen abweichen.
Dann werde ich die Patienten abdomenzonographieren.
Dann werden wir die Patienten abdomenzonographieren.
Dann werden wir die Schmerzen abdomenzonographieren.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtdiagnose veranleite, werde ich den Patienten Schutteltest veranlassen.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtdiagnose veranleite, werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann werde ich die Patienten an der Analyse und Antiprätik veranlassen.
Dann werde ich die Patienten eine schulische Konsil anordnen, um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie sich mit dieser Vergabenweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit den geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Herr Kollegen, welche Therapiemöglichkeiten hat dieser Patienten?
Nach der Akutbehandlung werde ich den Patienten, die ich empfehle, die Patienten, Tätigkeit essen, zu vermeiden.
Gibt es Medikamentos- und Operativtherapie oder andere Therapiemethoden?
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Therapiemethoden.
Aber wenn es den Patienten viele Komplikationen gibt, wie z.B. starke Entzündungen oder hochwärte Blurubin,
oder es gibt eine Steine im Galengange, denke ich eine Operation.
Wenn der Patient unter 1 cm Stein im Galengange bläst, was empfehlen Sie?
Ja, ich empfehle eine Operation.
Nur, wenn der Patient unter 1 cm Stein im Galengange bläst, was empfehlen Sie?
Aber es gibt keine Empfehlung.
Einstein kann mit der ESW-Therapie oder RSP-Möglichkeiten gehen.
Ja, Endoskopik-Retrograt.
Können Sie RSP, Herr Kollegen?
Ja, RSP ist eine Eingriffenunterzuchtung.
Mit dieser Unterzuchtung können wir die Organe und die Galen Blase beurteilen.
Diese Unterzuchtung hilft uns, wenn wir krank sind, wie die Kolosis oder die Kolalität.
Herr Kollegen, diese Unterzuchtung hilft uns nur, wenn der Stein im Koledok, Dr. Pankleotikus oder Ampulla im Galen Blase nicht hilft.
Ich habe nicht viel Erfahrung über dieses Thema. Nach der Simulation lesen wir das Thema.
Vielen Dank Herr Kologun. Ich habe eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt, ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen über Sie berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Ich berichte über die 39-jährige Patientin, Frau Anna Müller, die 1,69 Meter groß ist und 68 Kilogramm wiegt.
Die Patientin stellte sich heute bei uns mit seit gestern Abend bestehenden, drückenden, koligartigen, epigastrischen Schmerzen rechts vor.
Außerdem erwähnte, dass ihre Beschwerden nach dem fettigen Esseneinnahmen angefangen haben.
Darüber hinaus berichtete sie über nächtliche Hyperhydrose, Schüttelfrost, Fieber, Nausea und einmal Emesis, akkulischen Stuhl und Bilirubinüri.
Fragen nach Gewichtsveränderungen, Ichterus, Obstipation und Diarrhea wurden vermeint. Einnahme von 400 mg Ibuprofen hat kaum Linderung gebracht.
Die Patientin leidet an Migräne seit 10 Jahren, Arterialhypertonie seit 5 Jahren, Hyperkolesterolomie seit 5 Jahren und Lumbar-Gesetzalgie seit 5 Jahren.
Vor 3 Jahren hatte sie eine Hyperzosterinfektion.
Sie nehme regelmäßig 20 mg morgens, ab Ende April 10 mg einmal pro Tag, Triptan 10 mg und Ibuprofen 400 mg, wenn es bedarf.
Bei der Patientin ist keine Operation bekannt und Fragen nach Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten wurden vermeint.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft, sie ist nicht Raucherin und sie trinkt 1 oder 2 Glas Wein pro Monat. Drogenkonsum wurde vermeint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass ihr Vater an Hepatocelialcarcinom vor 5 Jahren gestorben ist.
Ihre Mutter leidet an Arterialhypertonie, Diabetes mellitus und Osteoporose.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat 2 gesunde Kinder. Sie lebt mit ihrer Familie und arbeitet als Büroangestellter.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf Cholesistitis hin.
Differentialdiagnostik kommen Hepatitis, Cholelytiasis, Pancreas, Kopfcarcinom und Hepatocelialcarcinom in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Patientin zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich bei der Patientin Blut abnehmen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob es Abwehrspannung gibt oder Mörfeseichen gibt.
Oder Fermerthe, Darmgeräusch oder Peristaltism gibt.
Oder Icterus, Acitis gibt.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen, besonders werde ich großes Blutbild bestimmen lassen.
Entzündungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Und Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Direkt und Indirekt-Bilirubin.
Und CA19-9 und CA125 bestimmen lassen werde ich.
Und Hepatiserologie bestimmen lassen.
HBS-AG, Anti-HBS, Anti-HCW bestimmen lassen.
Entzündungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Und ALP, LDH auch bestimmen lassen.
Apparativdiagnostik werde ich zuerst Abdomen- und Sonografie durchführen.
Um mögliche Cholestitis zu bestätigen.
Und Cholelytiasis auch zu bestätigen.
Und mögliche Leberkarzinom und Pancreaskarzinom auszuschließen.
Ggf. werde ich CT des Abdomens durchführen.
Wenn die Befunden unklar sind, wird CT hilfreich und sinnvoll in diesem Patienten.
Natürlich werde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestimmen und die nötigen Behandlungen zu beginnen.
Und ein gastroenterologisches Konzil ist sinnvoll.
Oder ein chirurgisches Konzil ist sinnvoll.
Um mögliche Operationen zu verändern.
Zu planen.
Herr Oberers.
Ok.
Ja.
Also was erwarten Sie bei einer Sonografie?
Bei dieser Patienten?
Ja.
In diesem Fall erwarte ich bei der Patienten eine verdichte Gallenblase Muskel oder
Haut.
Wir können auch eine Gallenblase Wand ödem sehen.
Und wenn es Steine gibt, können wir die Steine bestimmen.
In der Gallenblase oder in der Gallenwege auch.
Wir können bestimmen.
Ok.
Herr Kollegen, kennen Sie die Risikofaktoren?
Besonders bei einer Cholecystolithiasis oder Choleidokalithiasis?
Ja, die Patienten leiden unter Hypercholesterenemie.
Deswegen ist das ein Risikofaktor.
Und die fettige Ernährung oder fettiges Essen ist auch ein Risikofaktor.
Und bei der Familiengeschichte, in der Familiengeschichte von Leberkarzinom
kann es auch ein Risikofaktor für Lebererkrankungen geben.
Kennen Sie 6F Risikofaktoren?
6F, ja.
Familie, ja das ist Frau zu sein.
Weiblich, genau.
Weiblich und Familiegeschichte.
Fettiges Essen vielleicht, ich vermute.
Fett, also Adipös.
Adipös, ja Adipös, Fett.
Und ja, kenne ich andere nicht.
Also auf Englisch fair, wir sagen heller Hauttyp.
Heller Hauttyp, ok.
Und über 40, also das.
Über 40.
Und fair, fair, fair.
Auf Englisch wir sagen fruchtbar.
Auf Deutsch.
Schwangerschaft.
Ok, ja, fruchtbar.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Ok, super.
Ja, und kennen Sie die Komplikationsmöglichkeiten
bei einer Cholesistitis oder Cholesistolitis?
Ja, Cholesistitis kann, wenn die Behandlung
ist verspätet, das kann ein Sepsis verursachen,
wenn wir Behandlung langsam beginnen oder Verspätung gibt.
Oder eine Perforation kann auch eine mögliche Komplikation.
Und natürlich die Cholesistitis kann ein Pancreatitis verursachen.
Und das kann eine lebensbedrohliche Situation sein.
Diese Komplikationen kennen wir.
Sehr gut.
Ok, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Murphy Zeichen kontrollieren würden.
Können Sie bitte Murphy Zeichen erklären?
Ja, bei Murphy Zeichen tasten wir Oberbau rechts ab unter Rippen.
Und wir möchten die Patienten tief einatmen.
Und wenn die Patient hat Atemstillstand,
wenn die Atem stoppt, das zeigt, und hat Schmerzen natürlich,
das zeigt ein Positives Murphy Zeichen.
Und ein Positives Murphy Zeichen zeigt eine Cholesistitis oder Cholesistolitis.
Ok, gut. Und würden Sie bei dieser Patientin ein EKG schreiben?
Ja, auf jeden Fall ein EKG schreiben.
Oberbau Schmerzen sind manchmal atypisch.
Wenn es im Herz rechts und unter Wand Infarkt ist,
kann das auch ein Oberbau rechts Schmerzen verursachen.
Deswegen müssen wir auf jeden Fall ein EKG schreiben.
Ok, und Sie haben gesagt, dass als Difference-Year-Diagnose
ein Pankreaskarzinom kommt.
Welche Symptome sprechen gegen ein Pankreaskarzinom bei dieser Patientin?
Ja, das ist ein akuter Fall.
Deswegen ist Pankreaskarzinom ein bisschen schwer zu bewerben.
Ein bisschen chronisch, Pankreatitis kann akut symptomatisch sein.
Aber die Patientin leidet unter akulischem Stuhl
und hat starke Oberbau Schmerzen.
Diese Beschwerden sprechen für Pankreaskarzinom.
Aber auf jeden Fall muss sich Pankreatis-Enzyme bestimmen lassen.
Um mögliche Pankreatitis auszuschließen.
Ok, sehr gut. Sie haben es gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank. Und Herr Oberas, wenn Phrenixin ist auch betroffen,
oder betroffene Phrenixin-Nerv, kann ein rechts Schulterschmerzen verursachen.
Das ist eine Ausstrahlung Schmerzen.
Ich denke auch, hinzufügen.
Und wenn die Patientin eine Rückenschmerzen hat,
was denken Sie? Welches Nervsystem ist betroffen?
Ich meine bei der Pankreaskarzinom?
Rückenschmerzen. Welches Nerv?
Ja, da habe ich keine Informationen über diesen Thema, Herr Oberas.
Ich freue mich darauf, wenn ich bei Ihnen lerne.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, Herr Oberas.
Aber ich glaube, dass es eine gute Fälle in der Angriffe hat.
Murat hat in der Angriffe einen schönen Nerv gemacht.
Das ist wie eine Rückenschmerzen.
Denn manchmal kommen Pankreatis-Karzinom-Nervfälle.
Ja, das ist eine Gür-Teleformik.
Aber Prenixinner kann kommen.
Prenixinner, rechts, Hübsch.
Wir haben noch nicht gesagt, dass es eine Ausstrahlung ist.
Pankreatis-Karzinom ist eigentlich unerhört.
Nicht wahr, Herr Oberas?
Das ist generell ein Geist.
Es gibt auch Rückenschmerzen.
Die Pankreatis-Karzinom-Nervfälle.
Ich bin ein sehr harten Arzt.
Kann ich das Wort von Fetiges Essen wiederholen?
Fetiges Essen, das ist das, was Ari Schapan in der ersten Hälfte vorgetragen hat.
Aus Erdem, das ist das, was ich in der ersten Hälfte gesagt habe.
Das ist falsch.
Da ist etwas, es ist wie ein Gericht.
Aus Erdem erwähnte sie das ihre Beschwerden nach dem Fetiges Essen Einnahme angefangen haben.
Nach dem Versehen von Fetiges Essen.
Also, so kann man es sagen.
Nach der Einnahme von Fetiges Essen.
Die Einnahme.
Nach der Einnahme.
Danke.
Ich habe heute noch einiges zu tun.
Ich kann das Programm nicht aufhören.
Ich muss heute noch mal auf einem Ort sein.
Herr Peyman kann jetzt die Rolle spielen.
Ich habe noch ein Programm, aber es wäre gut, wenn wir es heute noch machen.
Wir können es heute noch bis 8 Uhr machen.
Können wir es heute noch bis 8 Uhr machen?
Ja, das ist gut.
Dann sagen wir es bis 6 Uhr morgen.
Okay.
Schönen Abend.
Bis bald.